each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon we are going to start the
the last section of this day the name of
the section is perspectives on health
intelligence we're going to introduce
three speakers but by the first time I
would like to introduce myself my name
is Laila ponch's I'm representing Jason
Lima Silva the scientific director of
foundation supporting science
technology innovation in Rio de Janeiro
I'd like to thank you very much
microsoft and they are organizing to
invite me to be a chair of this section
is an honor for us and a compliment and
to work with you to establish a very
good technological site for developing
TI in rio de janeiro i'm also a teacher
of federal federal institute of rio de
janeiro that work with several kinds of
fields in technology also we're going to
start the lecture of introduce dr. seuss
a cloud teheh each speaker going to have
15 minutes are going to conclude our
lecture and by the end of the three
lectures going to have 15 minutes for
questions and i'm going to introduce the
next speed speaker my cells are called
is key the presentation title is in fact
Obama bio magical amazing on health care
I'm talking a little bit about his bio
daughter Djokovic's is an assistant
professor in the Department of Computer
Science at the University of Sao Paulo
and then is the magical imaging
prior to that who was postdoctoral
fellow and held a research scientist
position and Ariel University in the
Department our diagnosis in aging his
research is orientated towards
developing scale scalable biomedical
image analysis methods he says been
principal investigator of several a pest
in CNP cal grants collaborate sac italy
with a chin ola a martino center for by
biomedical imaging thank you very much
introduction while i'm glad to be here
today it's probably it's actually my
second time in the microsoft event is
probably in what four years since my
first attendance and i'm very glad to
see all the technologies that being
portrayed throughout this event
throughout these two days today in
particular i would like to show with you
share with you actually what we've been
doing with imaging and medical imaging
specifically I've seen some of the
imaging technology or image applications
have been you know under works with
Microsoft I know there is a all there's
whole sector on biomedical imaging up in
the US and just like to disclose some of
the stuff that we do and show what are
the challenges that we have how we have
to deal with when we deal with medical
ended medical domain rather just looking
at images in which we deal with visible
light as we know all these medical
biomedical imaging techniques such as
ultrasound CT MRI pads is packed scans
astrology for studying pathology all
these things have become really powerful
diagnostic tools for all doctors it
helped not only for diagnosis but also
for therapeutical protocols now as you
can imagine everybody that anyone that
actually goes to a hospital to undergo
one of such exams well of course you're
worrying about what's going on with your
body okay that's why you're going in
there all these images are actually
stored
impact system or databases which our
database system of images and all these
imaging centers and a major concern is
that nothing is actually performed no no
analysis actually performed on those
images after the patient leaves the
hospital so the big question is that I
that's something that me may want to
discuss here in the panel afterwards is
is there something useful that can be
you know can be done with it I mean is
there some statistic I can actually be
achieved from analyzing all these images
that are there and one of the key
challenges is these are all completely
different nature of images I mean they
come from different physical properties
you're measuring different physical
processes therefore we believe that
biomedical imaging in combination with
the clinical history of the patient and
as well as you know all the molecular in
proteomics and genomics actually
increase the knowledge about you see a
populations health care of populations
health and probably benefit healthcare
policies in the future so there's a huge
as Claudia stalling is about there's a
better half roughly 1 million of images
are a million exams are conducted just a
nice time any and you can imagine how
many different modalities what is the
percentage of all these that are
actually you know splitting this million
or so and this is within just one
institution can you imagine in all the
centers around the world and even here
in Rio or San Paulo okay which
concentrates to all the major medical
institutions here in Brazil so if this
amount of information will actually
overwhelm individual machines as you
know doctors used to use their own
laptops and workstations back 15 years
ago which now is completely unrealistic
if you really want to perform a
large-scale statistic analysis on on
patient databases so another key point
is each one of these images they have
they are generated by different probes
different imaging devices and each of
them actually generate a signature is so
they are different in terms of their
nature and in terms of the noise
characteristics and this is another
challenge when we try to devise
machine learning algorithms or even in
statistical analysis tools to be able to
cope with all these nevertheless what we
want is to continue this track
information so that we can quantify it
and perhaps you know share with our
peers especially other doctors around
the world the conclusions that you get
from your information that is sitting
there okay and ultimately this is how
we're going to improve health right by
sharing all this knowledge that has
actually been you know scattered in all
those database that I just remain unused
it up to now so what I'd like to show
you from this point on is three
applications that you know have been
developed or under de valor under
developing with our group back in
University some pollo and these are
student projects these are masters and
PhD projects and to show you how high
and can an application and medical image
be so the first example that I would
like to show you is on cardiovascular
disease and you see two images there on
the red eye on the left hand side you
see what we call the circle Willis in
circle well is is a is a is a sort of a
vassal architecture that is actually
located in the back of your brain and
helps actually communicate all the blood
vessels throughout the other you know
places in around your cortex and so on
as you see on the right hand side
there's a big pouch in another patient
as it showed by the yellow arrow and
this is what it announced aneurysm is so
is this little pouch that develops
regardless of their cause it may rupture
because of the you know bigger
elasticity that is associated with the
walls and if it ruptures we are in a big
big trouble now how can we help for
example detectives in an ultimatum
matter it's nurse not about looking at
the pixels themselves you need some
prior knowledge to understand that this
is actually a bad thing so in order to
do these things this this kind of
processes you need to learn what the
doctors do what they have actually
learned from their schooling okay and
then we can mimic the cognitive system
of the doctors themselves to be able to
put in those high end applications so in
this case whatever
like to show you that we can actually
reconstruct vessels in characterized
vessel problems synthesizing angiograms
why you want to try to build synthetic
vessel architectures so that we are able
to create a model from which we can
actually get the answers we are looking
for alright and this is sort of
mimicking the nature or how the
angiogenesis actually take place so what
you see here in this slide is is a
vessel architecture on the far left hand
side which gets process it and then
represented as a grammar so whole an
entire advanced or architecture can be
represented by a string and what we call
this a sequencing we call it a sequence
II like it this war because of the
genetics connotation to it and so if you
represent these as an expression we can
not only encode the information of the
structure of the vassals but also be
able to infer and make questions asked
queries to queries on the strength to
see is this how this is different from
normal okay and we can learn different
grammars according to different vassal
architectures that we want to probe for
and here show you some examples of the
vassal that can be easily accomplished
or created synthetically these are
angiograms are diffusion angiograms and
all the vessels that you see here they
represent pieces of different
architecture within different organs and
you can see in the figure J which is at
the bottom line you see those little red
arrows they actually show two anomalies
or abnormalities and one of them is
actually an aneurysm so if we're able to
create this effect in an artificial
image which can be corroborated with the
real images then we can actually ask the
question what kind of features from this
then can characterize an aneurysm and
then help diagnose this and help the
doctor easily locate is because this
patient doesn't really have much time
until it really needs to get operated
upon another so I'm going to switch
gears to a different application and
another one is sepsis a lot of as
Claudia was saying only a few doctors
like to wash their hands
okay so in a fact what happens is that
there is a when you go into the hospital
you undertake some kind of procedure and
it's very likely that you may end up
with bacterial infection which causes
inflammation and basically create a
systemic inflammatory response all of
your body and this can easily go leads
to death now the question is how you can
you detect this early enough so that you
can actually take the proper measures
and counter-attack this and to be able
to actually do this you need to look at
the very fine scale of what's happening
within your capillary system so with the
same idea we can use optical imaging
which takes video is a very microscopic
scale of the vessels and you can
actually see the blood cells streaming
through all these capillaries and thrall
time you can see that as bacteria starts
to spread out tissue becomes
inflammation and the vessels simply
cannot supply the oxygen anymore okay
now what is cool about this well we can
record a video of these in real time and
then we can apply our computer vision
and basically all the machine learning
techniques that you know we've come to
learn so far to diagnose this again this
is exactly what you've done with simple
support vector machines you're able to
categorize different levels of subsets
of commitment of sepsis giving a certain
patient cancer is another big topic of
course we don't know the exact mechanism
of this it's not i'm not here to tell
you about about that but we know that a
lot of thing modulates you see their
development ended and actually how it
happens at human body such as life
factors and environmental spouter there
is one particular kind of tumor or
cancer which is called a glioblastoma
and liberal stomas are very malignant
tumors that occur in the brain okay and
they're due to that arise from us glia
or specific cells that actually make up
the supported tissue the brain they
represent about fifteen percent of all
these tumors in our you know they spread
out very quickly so what we want to do
here is be able to at least give a sense
for the characterization of how this
tissue is actually actually being
affected how can actually tell that a
tissue is affected by this tumor
has tumor cells or not and more recently
there has been a greater advance in all
imaging techniques that we see okay and
one particular advance is what is called
diffusion imaging which is an MRI
modality that can actually probe for
tissue integrity and I'm going to save
you from the complex details because it
actually records proton diffusion in
ways to infer the integrity of tissues
now this has been readily used to
conserve at that let me go back to that
one to give the correct tries to issue
where versus tissue tissue normal tissue
versus tissue with some sort of an
abnormality in this case what you see on
your left hand side is a typical
intensity based imageable that really
doesn't really tell much except there is
a big blob which is definitely something
there is abnormal when you look at an
image like that on the right hand side
though you have a model you have an
image that tells much more information
about what's going on inside and all
this little red and blue and purplish
glyphs which looks like balls or spheres
but actually are super toroid super tall
whites okay and this is a German at the
same time there's a geometric model that
has been used to represent the
information from this this modality of
imaging by reducing the dimensionality
this is something that we are accustomed
to and the same time I can actually
probe for discriminative information and
now I can actually tell what is it Dima
from what is that tissue from what is
normal tissue and this is within reach
ok it's just we have the tools we have
the expertise and the manpower to
accomplish things like that these are
very complex stuff so just to show you
how how bad this thing is on the top
line on the top row you actually see
maps of a normal brain and at the bottom
one you see maps of a person that has
actually died of it died of brain tumor
and the key thing is to learn how this
process is how this proliferation goes
on and how this actually tissue is
impacted impacted by this here's the
same similar picture showing
what's happening to the wiring of the
brain as a result of this mass expansion
so it's not because we have a tumors or
bad cells that reproduce and in an
uncontrollable way but also we are
confined to this call to the brain and
therefore everything gets pushed so this
is an so this constitutes three
different applications that we can
invest our efforts on this is just three
there are thousands of applications that
are there just waiting to be discovered
and in order to benefit you know our
healthcare system and our only health in
general so I'm thinking about I'm a
little too early today but what are my
conclusions here to be able to work with
medical imaging you actually need to
think outside the box so you cannot
simply go through your machine learning
algorithms or your statistical data
analysis and think that medical images
are simply made of pixels need to
understand what a pixel is in terms of a
physical property that's the first thing
second thing you need some how to
approach doctors you need to learn a bit
about Anatomy about physiology to be
able to understand a little bit about
human body third point you need to
understand the imaging techniques so
it's not like we always take for granted
when we see a digital picture made from
us you know cell phone camera or a
professional camera that has a CCD
there's some noise patterns associated
with it but we never really questioned
we assume that image is perfect and and
that's it I start from that here no you
need to understand what are the noise
characteristics of your device and what
kind of information is a give this is
very important so that we can actually
get the features that represent what
we're trying to assess and more recently
a lot of new techniques have been
developed okay so I've been in touch
with several groups around the world and
constantly constantly come with new
imaging devices and this imaging devices
now produce terabytes of information
it's not like a two-dimensional image or
a three-dimensional image now we're
talking about half a terabyte per
patient
now multiply this by a million if you
want to do across group analysis but all
the database of information that you
have a little hang in all these
hospitals or imaging centers you need to
be able to copy this and it is very rare
that hospitals or medical centers have
this IT power to accomplish such a thing
okay probably ice thing is is a rare
example here in Brazil so we this is the
what I would like to for you to happen I
would like to this data to be shared and
we you know we can always invest
ourselves into building some kind of
platform that will allow not only the
sharing of information for for doctors
it for do an exchange of information
between doctors and be able to tell you
see create newmanology devise new
therapeutics or new diagnostic tools
based on information in a way that
actually will make sense and improve
human health and I've seen the cloud
computing such a buzz word today and is
this is something that is here for us to
to stay and is actually being used for
this there are a bunch of efforts around
the world and try to create such a
platform to be able to analyze it
statistically all these images but so
far I haven't seen any major hospital
medical institution or you see that
actually embraced such a platform and I
think it's an opportunity that we would
like probably to discuss I think this is
something that is worth going and last
is that integration of imaging plus the
clinical history of the patient plus
demographics okay can tell a lot about
what's going on in your population and
this is completely disregarded and this
is something that you know I'm willing
to work on and I'm willing to share you
know what we have been doing in regards
to that with all of you so I thank you
thank you very much for the opportunity
thank you very much dr. Czajkowski for
your presentation and then shoot the
next introduce Michael the squad is key
demo presentation project premonition
presentation title project ammunition
preventive monitoring of infection
agents Michael Tchaikovsky and man is a
cross-discipline team of engineers in
the development research technology me
to scalable working solutions he works
with academic industry in government in
geo collaborators to build partnerships
and community ecosystems recently he has
been for cues on projects related to the
confluence of an aerospace in computer
science and engineering with projects
like window flow promote nation and the
red bull air races he also leads
research news online news aggregation
service for the academic research
community thank you very much for that
introduction it's a pleasure to be here
I'm very honored to be asked to be a
part of this panel and I was really glad
to see that Claudio didn't make a
joke because he would have got two for
one on this panel and and I probably
would have had to buy him a drink later
tonight so I'm here to talk about
premonition and this is a really
exciting project cross-discipline with
lots of challenges very ambitious and
I'm representing a much larger team than
just myself there are a lot of smart
people on this project and I thought I'd
just quickly go over the people in
microsoft research that are working on
this and some of their disciplines and
then also talk about our collaboration
with academia we have people on this
slide
from the programming languages area of
research artificial intelligence and
machine learning computational genomics
we actually have a few people on staff
in that area the hardware engineering
and and then research engineering and
there's a lot of collaboration that has
to happen inside Microsoft Research to
pull off a project like this and then
outside the core sort of computer
science research areas we've partnered
with a lot of other academic
institutions that specialize in
different areas of the domains that
we're exploring we've also been
fortunate enough to have joint funding
from the intelligence Advanced Research
Program Association I arpa who is
helping co-fund these universities so
it's really stretching our investment
dollars as well Vanderbilt pen
Pittsburgh UC Riverside who has some of
the most advanced mosquito analysis
people on their staff University of
Kansas and then John Hopkins University
and Doug Norris here is a world-renowned
mosquito expert so I'm really excited to
be here I know this is an interesting
topic for many parts of the world but
very interested in also connecting with
people in Latin America around potential
future collaborations so if anything you
see here looks like something you might
be interested in getting involved with
please come find me okay so um oops so
of course catastrophic diseases are very
impactful to humanity not only in the
loss of life or impact to health but
it's very expensive and even if the
diseases does not become an epidemic
they're very clearly very impactful
around the world and this is just an
example of the different types of
infectious diseases that we believe
could have
could see some improvement in an early
warning system and that's essentially
what we're trying to build is an early
warning system the original idea for
premonition was somewhat driven by
malaria and then Ebola that was back in
2014 we also have done exploration
around chikungunya and I'll talk a
little bit more in detail about a field
experiment we've attempted there but of
course Zika is is the next big thing it
doesn't seem like there's any lack of
opportunity to do better in this space
and we're continuing to evolve our
thinking and our exploration of how we
can help these different early warning
systems for these different diseases so
in a baseline here just on a couple
things before I drill in the project you
know the 60 over sixty percent of
disease emergency events are passed from
animals to humans and this is a really
important aspect because there's lots of
things happening out there in the
environment especially with animals that
aren't really a problem until they get
into the human population and the
interesting thing about that is to the
current state of the art and to predict
when that's going to happen or the
impact of how that transition happens
called zoo osas it takes about two weeks
for the World Health Organization to
actually come up with a declaration that
there is an outbreak of something that
we need to do something about and that's
a long time and we believe we can
implement a system that will help us
actually see what's happening in the
environment ahead of time so we can be
much better prepared and try to contain
these things the other interesting stat
that we've come up with is that when
there are pathogens found in the
environment it's believed in that over
seventy percent of those are really
unknown in the scientific community
today and that's kind of a scary
statistic because we don't necessarily
even know what's out there that can
cause
problems and so the more even if we find
things in the environment that aren't
necessarily a problem yet we can be
better prepared and better better
understand the environmental effects of
these things okay so um just like I'm
look down here so we need better
environmental surveillance and we want
to see what's circulating and the
animals before they impact humans a
little bit of a spoiler alert we want to
build an autonomous large-scale self
adapting cyber-physical system I like
that term really it's a you know
something that has the smarts and the
capability to go out in the world and
collect information for us that help us
make better decisions so there's three
key innovative tracks part of this
project it's very ambitious and all
three of these things are very
challenging the first is that we want to
build a smarter mosquito trap we believe
mosquitoes are a sensor in the world
that we can take advantage of they go
around naturally collect blood samples
for us and then can return those blood
samples to us via this process existing
mosquito traps are very low throw
throughput they must be hand placed by
experts and require a lot of manual
processing so that's one of the
technology areas that were working on
and if you came to demo fest I have our
prototype with me the other one is the
advancement of drone technology and
there's so much happening in this space
it's really exciting there are some
really hard challenges there around safe
autonomous operation in unknown
environments and we are working on a
stack of technologies that help us make
sure that the system is reliable and
verified and secure up through
controllable to all the way to the
high-level decision making so that these
things can go out and deploy these traps
in smart ways they can deploy them in an
air
whether we believe there is going to be
mosquitoes and then we can go retrieve
them to retrieve the mosquitoes and
finally the third piece is the
metagenomics as we collect more
information from the environment we need
to scale up our ability to process this
information and it's kind of what Marcel
alluded to in his talk this is a really
important area we want to sequence the
DNA from the mosquito us and and
evaluate what its blood characteristics
and the protein characteristics what
pathogens its carrying and what it may
have actually bitten will be done on
friday okay so i mentioned mosquito as a
device they grow naturally in the
environment there they don't select
certain homesteads they're pretty
they're pretty ubiquitous they like to
bite lots of things and so we can get a
broad scale understanding of what's
happening in the animal world and this
actually isn't a new idea there are
classical entomological methods that
that are used to collect mosquitoes but
they're as I mentioned earlier they're
very cumbersome and this is something
that we can leverage to help our
understanding of how to make it better
so this is a picture from the island of
Grenada we actually did a field
experiment we kind of did a baseline to
see okay is this project really crazy
can we actually pull this off what do we
think we would need to do this is the
state-of-the-art mosquito trap and it is
literally a little igloo cooler where
the some dry ice is put into it the dry
ice emits carbon dioxide which is a
primary lure for mosquitoes that's why
mosquitoes bite you you breathe out
carbon dioxide they go ah lunch
the rest of the trap hanging below that
is a net and it includes a ultraviolet
light mosquitoes are also attracted to
ultraviolet light it's attached to a big
heavy battery at the bottom the
mosquitoes and a bunch of other stuff
fly into this netted trap and end up in
the bottom of this container and they're
typically left out you know 18 hours
they're placed and then the field
biologists will and placed by hand very
heavy very cumbersome and then we'll
come back 18 hours later to retrieve it
hopefully the local teenagers didn't do
something weird to it like treated like
a pinata this is Doug Norris I mentioned
him earlier this is what comes back this
is the bug goo that you get out of the
trap and it takes somebody like this to
then separate the mosquitoes out of the
bug goo and this is literally the state
of the art process that's used today you
can imagine how time-consuming and
expensive this process is to get a
understanding of what's happening in the
environment so this is our vision for
what the trap should be able to do we're
still evolving our thinking we're
working on different prototypes but this
is really the high level we want to do
selective trapping so if we can just
trap a mosquito or even just the ages
Egypt I mosquito then we don't have to
do any separation we have the we have
the mosquito we want we have the sensor
information we want we want it to be low
power low cost so these are easy and
cheap to make no moving parts we want to
make these available to the world this
isn't really a business that Microsoft
is looking to get into we're really
thinking about this as something that we
can work on together to help solve this
problem for Humanity in situ
stabilization the mosquito needs to stay
alive for as long as possible otherwise
its DNA and blood structures start
breaking down and we don't get as much
information out of it or it becomes
unreliable and we want
I guess we need low-cost emitters
different sensors to determine if it is
a mosquito that's entering in the trap
so this is where we're at today this is
if you came to the demo fest this is
what I was showing it mostly works this
was a very early prototype as very early
stages of the project but we've had
really good success with this device
this is completely custom designed and
built in-house and MSR it has about 68
cells and they are designed to capture
one mosquito it's heavy but it works
we've tested it in a laboratory
environment it works by looking at the
signal of mosquitoes and these are the
top line or what's a measured wing
frequency beat of the mosquitoes and the
bottom are the the classification we use
those with the IR sensor in the trap to
determine whether or not it's a mosquito
and we had over ninety percent success
rates with this trap in a laboratory
environment one of the interesting
surprises that happen for us is as we
were running this experiment we noticed
by collecting the semantic metadata
around when these mosquitoes were
entering the trap we could find patterns
in their behaviors that weren't
previously documented there had been
some studies in entomology around how
mosquitoes behave and how different
mosquitoes behaved this chart on the
bottom is the AGS egyp die and it has a
much more aggressive behavior than the
mosquito on the Left which has a more
circadian rhythm and this will help us
in understanding better how to place the
traps and maybe how to be more effective
in our capturing of these bugs I'm going
to have to start moving faster but I did
want to show this this is actually our
laboratory experiment and this is Ethan
Jackson one of our leading researchers
on the project and if the video I don't
know if I can get that video to play
anyway this is in the UC Riverside
laboratory where we were able to get
such good results with the trap okay so
that's the trap that's the trap
challenge we also need to solve the
drone challenge and there are a lot of
people working on this there's a lot of
universities Oregon there's a lot of
Industry people working on this work
we've currently broken this down to just
four components as I mentioned earlier
that secure OS layer the sensing layer
making sure we can control the device
and then the high level planning
ultimately from the reliable platform
all the way to decision making under
uncertainty I'm going to go through
these pretty quickly because I know I'm
running over the idea on the secure OS
side is that we're leveraging tools
already being worked on and delivered
from Microsoft Research XIII and boogie
are already available verve OS is
another one we're building out and the
idea is that this is a fully verified
and functionally correct system that
when it's deployed we have a high
confidence level that it's going to work
correctly in the sensing space we have
some of the smartest researchers and
computer vision machine learning and
some of the best tools in the industry
that we can leverage to help in
understanding the environment as the
drones out there in sensing the
environment understanding what it's
seeing and providing classification of
that environment information up to the
next level so that then decisions can be
made in the correct control space it's
our focus here is really on the
degradation of signals and information
if everything's working perfectly okay
yeah it's pretty easy to fly a drone
around if you start losing information
or things become unreliable or maybe you
lose a signal that's where things get
interesting and we're really excited
about some of our work here and we have
a paper coming out in a robotics
conference in a couple months and then
finally you know the high-level planning
and this is really where the artificial
intelligence component comes in how do
you
no where to place the traps how do you
know to avoid this area or that you want
to go to this area and there's a lot
that goes into this this is a very rich
area of research right now and we're
actively studying that too okay so that
really was me out there I am a drone
pilot I'm actually a real aircraft pilot
and I'm an aerospace engineer so my
specialty is really in that domain but
like Rico mentioned at the opening of
this event it's really important to work
across domains as well and that's really
what's making this project work is that
people are learning each other's
languages we're combining computer
science we're pulling together the
different domains and that's when the
magic happens it's when you get these
heart problems together and people from
different domains working together and
understanding each other's languages
understanding each other's problems and
then coming up with solutions that can
really change the world I'm just going
to maybe I'll talk about this quickly
this is the the third trajectory this is
around the genomics problem you know you
have the problem of the host and vector
the microbes inside the blood and the
proteins there's a lot of people on this
project working on this problem but
especially as it relates to the
healthcare space this is a great area
for us to collaborate on eventually this
is what we want to get to we want to
improve our understanding this is from
health mapped org and the numbers are
pretty small in this chart we want to
increase this by at least an order of
magnitude and it'll and at least 10
orders of magnitude in terms of
frequency of understanding and that's
about it thank you very much
and thank you Mike I would like to thank
our three speakers for the outstanding
and lectures on health intelligence and
you can start for questions first I'm
going to do to make my first the first
class in viman okay and we know the
Brazil is a challenge for health health
intelligence and healthcare and for the
few difficulty about you as a huge
country how you treat think we can
overcome this problem as soon as I
weekend using a health intelligence and
make a translation medicine available
for all the population even for the the
more the poor and in the distance places
in Brazil hello I think that we have
evolved a long way from attack either so
in a way that we're able now to have
doctors in really remote regions and
being able to relay their exams or
medical reports back to you know big
centers and be able to actually get the
second analysis and if they are unsure
what they're seeing and get back to the
you know to those remote regions back
and in a way trying to enhance what's
happening another point that I'd like to
make is also i hope that the government
is also have to have this conscience of
is trying to spread out this efforts
throughout the country more evenly okay
and I think Institute's like Einstein
and
different hospitals are actually doing
the same effort and try to create small
centers around the country and this will
disseminate not only the experience from
the doctors but also the technology that
has been developed so far so I think I
think we're on a good direction I don't
know if I could improve on either one of
those that was great I I totally agree i
think collection of dating of the the
big data you know paradigm shift is here
and with that comes you know the machine
learning technologies and allows us to
do a lot more things with all that
information so you know fundamental to
that though is access to the data and
it's it can be challenging to share that
information i see that in in in
different industries and healthcare i
think is one of those there's a lot of
privacy concerns and regulatory issues
and those can kind of get in the way of
knowledge and knowledge sharing and you
know i really encourage you know the
community to think about ways that we
can work around those issues because i
think that could really could help
explode our understanding and knowledge
sharing and then yeah experience sharing
the experience i totally agree with that
i also would maybe just add that it's
that collaboration between different
domains that I really think is important
and I've seen things go sideways when
people don't even really understand the
same language and not necessarily
Portuguese versus English but health
care versus computer science you talk
about things different ways different
domains have different ways of thinking
about things and if you can combine
those things and learn each other's
domain languages you can really find
some interesting simple solutions to
problems and that's where I've seen the
magic happen so maybe the combination
thank you very much now kill before I'll
just
listen everybody wants to party
fashion to doctors is called the syscall
ski this solution this idea of a drone
taking the the traps for love the
mosquitoes usually they you have to fly
over cities like ryu or cities like in
Africa or in other parts of the world
where they could be victims of people
trying to shoot them or to capture them
to sell them how do you cope with this
kinds of problematic issues that could
happen to the project that's a great
question maybe I don't know if you heard
about the guy that that shot one with a
shotgun and that was flying over his
backyard he thought it was watching his
wife sunbathe next to the pool and I
think there's a first off I think
there's a really big PR issue around
drones and I understand the concerns
around privacy and the right to not be
on somebody's camera but also balancing
that with the benefits that these drones
can provide and believe it or not
there's been a lot of studies in the
aerospace industry around the safety of
unmanned vehicles versus manned vehicles
or peopled vehicles and and the safety
and reliability of these automatic
systems are actually better than human
error normally even with a very highly
trained pilot so I think that those type
of perceptions are something that we
need to work on and garner the support
of the community at large of course you
know that's not going to solve all the
problems and I think our approach is
really around making it as safe as
possible so that if something bad
happens if there's a bad actor and they
decide they're going to take it down
that we try to have enough robustness in
the system that when things go wrong
that it fails gracefully and I think
that's about as good as we can do
by keeping things somewhat inexpensive
and simple and hopefully you know people
won't see a need to do that for monetary
gain but that's the best answer I have
today now I'd like to thank in the name
of Microsoft to research summit clown
suit aha Marcel Jacoby ski and mike is
called is key and they like
you